[Music]
paul is with us paul
is in jacksonville florida hi paul how
are you
hey dave how are you uh very exciting to
uh
finally be talking to you you too
uh how here's the thing so i am
four months away from being debt free
and um i have zero i'm fit well i'm 55
years old
and i have zero for retirement
i come out of a bad uh divorce
and had to pay a lot of debt and
so but i'm four months away and my
question is
is uh what's the best thing for me to do
i mean to invest money to do
i have no idea okay
uh well what we're going to teach you to
do is to be debt free then your next
goal is to have your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
right and then once you've done that you
start investing 15
of your income into retirement do you
own a home
uh no i do not okay are you planning on
buying a home
well it's kind of a funny thing uh i i i
got
remarried and the woman
uh the love of my life
who i got married to she owns her home
so that's where i am okay
well we we are married and we have a
paid for house right
okay that's a pretty good deal you got
there
yeah right well it's no it's not it's
not as cut and dry as that but uh
well well let me have you all combined
your finances paul because you're using
a lot of her and i
statements here like we got separate
things going on uh
no ma'am no ma'am she was married before
and obviously i was married before and
when we went into the relationship uh
she wanted a prenup so that's what we
did
oh that's what i did and um
that does not prohibit you from working
together
to live your dreams yes sir a prenup
does not make you roommates
well and that is the word that i used
with her one time we had gotten into
a discussion of that and um she
she has it in her head that she
wants to keep it this way and because
she said there's no upside
for me if you know we combined
everything
and because she i'm self-employed
and she uh she makes a lot more money
than i do
[Music]
okay um i i think you're uh i think
you're going to struggle
to build wealth yes sir i i because
we're not working together
is essential it's one of the data points
that we see with families that
become wealthy is they work together and
they overcome they
overcome the wounds and the hurts of the
past in order to do that
and uh you're either gonna you know it's
up to you you can do it or not do it but
i'm just telling you that
everything we know about what we do says
that couples that work together have a
much higher probability of living their
dreams
because they are sharing their dreams
and this is not just financial
like i mean i hear it in his voice dave
like this is whether it's because she's
been hurt from her past marriage and she
wants to protect herself
in this new one but but there is some
distrust
not even just at the financial level
that is i think playing out in the
finances and to me that's worth digging
into paul with a counselor or however
you guys want to go about it it's not
just about the numbers and
who manages which account and who has
savings or paid for house it's like
if y'all can't be a team in a marriage
that's a bigger problem
than having separate bank accounts i
just i would say
aside from the obvious financial benefit
that dave has already talked about i
would dig into that because even hearing
it in your voice it sounds a lot like
her and me and we're very separate type
of language and that's
that's a little bit uh concerning to me
it's um
but but aside from that the answer to
your overall question is
you start investing since you don't have
a house payment and i'm
guessing that you're not having to
support kids in college or you would
have mentioned that
then you're down to all you can your
most
you have taken the shortest path to
building your own nest egg
uh which is to become debt free and so
normally we would put you at baby step
four after this but you don't have a
house payment so really you're baby step
seven
and so once you get your emergency fund
in place you're gonna max out
all retirement that you can get your
hands on max out a roth ira with a
smart vester pro max out your 401 k at
work or you said you're self-employed
you look at a for uh a simple ira there
or a sep
depending on your situation smartvestor
pro can help you with both of those
so depending on your income you can
really chunk a bunch of money away
quickly
and uh you'd be amazed how big a mistake
in 10 years from 55 to 65 that you can
build
now that you don't have any payments and
you can focus on that and concentrate on
that
it will be uh
it will be much more efficient and have
a higher probability of
winning if you'll go ahead and deal with
the issues in the relationship as well
that christie's talking about
just again we we do not see people
uh winning at this so let me just back
up folks from this because it feels like
i've done this
twice already in this hour um haven't i
similar similar questions like that um
when we studied the millionaires over 10
000 of them
and we did in-depth research
and surveying and questioning of them
uh one of the things that came out of
that a lot of things that came out that
were not a surprise
and this was not a surprise but what was
a surprise was the
how high the percentages were of
spouses working together sharing the
dream one of them's not dragging the
other one along
one of them's not uh you know you're not
treating their household separately
uh you know we work together we achieve
our goals together we set big dreams we
both dream we both fight to get there
and that that unity the power of that
unity
uh was apparent in the in
very high percentages yeah in the number
of millionaires that we
researched over 10 000 of them yeah and
so it's not like the
the data is inconclusive it's conclusive
right
you know and so you can you do it
without working with your spouse yeah
you can do it
but you're you know 80 of the people
that make it
don't don't don't they work together
right and so it just
and they and they credit their spouse as
one of the reasons that they
are able to get the thing done this is
the dave ramsey show